my name is maureen Baer and I'm here
with Benjy Bernstein and been kicker and
our fourth partner is connect Blake who
is not with us today but has been very
instrumental in working on both this app
and the the work that will be shed that
Ben will be presenting on Thursday so
just a tiny bit of background about me I
am a wolfram hobbyist for about ten
years
I am hobbyist means that I have found
two people who can code better than me
now but I could still manage it as a
manager of what it is that we're looking
to do and that's one of the things I
love about well firm I am post corporate
organization and strategy both as a
consultant and in-house at American
Express for many years
I love wolfram because it can glue
anything together and it does not make
me have to use a lot of different kinds
of software and applications I've been
working on two different projects in the
philanthropic space the broad
philanthropic space I think social
impact would be a better way to put it
and we're going to present one today and
what on Thursday the one that we'll be
presenting on Thursday is about the
sustainable development goals and how to
use wolfram and the full Wolfram stack
or a lot of it as glue to tie together a
lot of disparate things that are
existing out in the world of data around
the sustainable development goals when I
was here three years ago I started
talking about the sustainable
development goals it's a 15 year project
the UN in the world to try to make the
world better and among others John keel
who's here today was very encouraging
I had a great presentation that said I
would be back in a year with a whole lot
done and I'm back in three years and
didn't we didn't do half of it but we
did a lot and we also came up with with
a second business area that we wanted to
look at in philanthropic area you've
probably heard the phrase impact
investment
in fact investment is the the idea that
you can do social impact have social
impact and get a reasonable financial
return we started an organization called
starting up good about five years ago
cadet and I started it it's it's a pro
bono organization working with startups
to help them figure out how to
incorporate social impact into their
startup models we did a lot of Silicon
Valley conferences and we were preaching
to the non converted at that point the
VC model was and was in full bloom at
that point so they would say that's cool
and we're gonna do what the VCS tell us
to do over over the past five years what
we've seen is a lot of demand for
investments that have both social impact
return and financial return so we're not
talking philanthropy here we're talking
real investments just to give you a
sense of the sizing it's increased 25
fold from 2013 to 2017 in terms of
assets under management so what we
decided is the startups are listening a
little bit more now there are multiple
models for how to get startup money and
the impact investing model is holding
its own actually there's there's a lot
of new investors who are interested in
investing in startups that have social
impact and that's not necessarily
because they're philanthropic it's
because more and more of their owner
investors are looking for endowments or
looking for private equity investors are
looking for things that have decent
social impact return as well so based on
that we decided to start to build we're
calling it an app but it's really more
formative than an app at this point a
way to gather the information that is
and the data that is starting to exist
around impact investing and put it all
into one place using wool for a Minotaur
as our glue
and start to look at it and see what is
one of the things that are making impact
investors decide to go with certain
startups about with others so what
you're going to see today from Bengie is
some of our work in it what you'll also
see is that it's very formative in a lot
of different ways the the primary one
some of it is because we're still
learning but also the data is brand new
there was not there were not giant
impact investing databases before and
what that means because the field is
burgeoning is everybody's inventing
their own you'll see on Thursday that
the UN sort of sets the stage for most
of the sustainable development goal
stuff so it's much more standardised in
terms of data in the impact space we're
working with four defer databases that
have begun some of them have been around
for a couple of years some of them are
pretty brand new and trying to figure
out how to normalize them using wolfram
to do that to build a macro database
that will then allow startups to start
to explore impact investing
possibilities and what they might do as
a startup to model their companies in
ways that are attractive to impact
investors so with that I'll hand it over
to you Benji and yeah thank you all
right thank you very much Maureen for
the intro so just moving on to this next
slide Maureen just touched on it a bit
but basically this is a very burgeoning
and new space and because of that a lot
of the data that's being set up it's
really structured in all sorts of
different ways so when it came to really
starting to put this app together
obviously the first thing that we needed
was a real and large data set and data
sort to be able to use to actually
inform the analytics and analysis
happening and within the app form so
basically the four different companies
that we looked at that are all playing
in the impact investment space in some
way that Maureen alluded to earlier our
impact space B Corp gin and crunch base
but for the purposes of this
presentation we're going to show you
most of the data that we had around the
impacts
data source just because that tends to
be the most robust source within the
impact investing field right now in
terms of the deals the investors and the
companies all being structured neatly
together so as I'm sure all of you know
cleaning and parsing is not easy
specifically when you have unstructured
data that's coming in and its new so
obviously one of the things that we
spent a lot of our time doing in the
beginning of this process was really
working with some of the capabilities
within Wolfram to actually download
extract and then clean and parse the
data so using a variety of different
string manipulation functions that are
built into Wolfram here you'll see a
little snippet of code of just the
import obviously we have a lot more code
that deals with all the ways that we
cleaned and structured this data
originally but this was definitely
something that we spend a bulk of our
time doing in the early stages of this
apps development so moving on here sorry
it's the wrong way
moving on here we've heard some about
entity stores during Stephen Wolfram
sukhino last night he talked about it I
think at some of the other sessions
today people have mentioned it and their
utility as well and we always saw them
as something from the beginning that we
wanted to make a big part of this
process so after we actually
successfully downloaded all this data
and structured it we wanted to then
transition it over into the entity store
structure so that we could be actually
working with our own internal entities
store within Wolfram for linking
throughout our app and so some of the
reasons that we use an entity store up
here obviously they give you this very
easy and natural ability to link between
different data sets to actually
integrate Wolfram entities as well as
your own entities that you define into
existing data sets that you download
ability to build in interpreters again
they have that simplified built in data
visualization structure and then sort of
lastly well actually these two pieces
here together ultimately we'll want to
be able to call in and link to some of
the built in Wolfram entities that
already
says they'll be relevant in different
ways to the app that we're developing
and then finally because they're just
easy to convert it's easy to combine and
recombine and append new data to enter
these stores and we found that it was
actually better than other structures
within Wolfram to use and so what you'll
see here are some defined functions that
we actually built and just before I get
into explaining them a little bit one of
the things that we saw was that we were
really used to analyzing data through
the data set format within wolfram and
we saw very early on as we started to
explore the entity store format that
there were really different advantages
to both the entity stores as well as to
the data sets and so we wanted to create
sort of these quick defined functions
that we would be able to use throughout
the apps development to be able to turn
data sets in the entity stores and then
turn them back and then that was all
before we heard Stephen Wolfram skeino
last night where he said that that is
gonna be something built in basically
into version 12 so we did all this work
and hopefully it'll still be the good
use but we'll definitely be using that
yeah yeah so currently it's being used
internally and we'll get into that how
we're using it exactly we have actually
ten clients that we've been sort of
testing it out with they've been helping
us develop it based on their own unique
needs and then sort of after we finish
this test phase the idea will be to then
move into getting it ready to be
industrial-strength and actually
modified to be public facing so just
moving on here to creating the actual
app form structure so let me just
reiterate what my colleague Maureen was
saying at the beginning of the
presentation so really there's all these
different great data sources that are
available right now in the impact
investing space but because it's such a
new space we weren't really seeing that
there was any real analysis being done
on this data in a uniquely concise way
that any startup looking to get into the
space could just access to be able to
actually have new information about what
would potentially be attractive to
impact investors so we wanted to really
meet this and
that we saw within the sector there so
again the idea is to create a platform
where startups can conveniently and
easily input information about their own
company and then receive an actual
report output from this form that we're
about to show you that includes really
similar peer startups so whether that be
in terms of their industry overlapping
you know geography social and
environmental objectives or even you
know getting very granular to their
actual business functions and models we
really want to be able to provide them
with a tool where they can access
different startups that have
successfully received impact investment
who are very akin to what they do so in
terms of the implementation I already
touched on this based on your question
but this is sort of what we're calling
the version one master forum and it's a
long format I'll take you through very
quickly but basically the idea centers
around a customized weighting system
that uses algorithmic string mashing
functions and I'll explain those a
little bit more in detail as we go
through as I mentioned before we're
using version one with this pilot group
of those ten clients to really just
tailor it as best to their needs and to
what they say you know is most important
to them as people coming into the space
and looking for impact investment and
then again this long form will be
modified as we continue to move forward
in the development process here so if
I'll just take you through a quick
example I'm actually having asked for
permission to do this from one of our
clients but I'm going to use them as a
case study here for how the form
actually works made meals is a company
that is doing really interesting things
and is really positioning themselves
right now to actually be attractive to
impact investors and so what they do is
that are basically a farm-to-table app
that pairs local farmers with consumers
who want a more healthy lifestyle and
actually delivers you know fresh produce
to these consumers to be able to allow
them with convenience to have a
healthier diet so essentially that's
that's the main idea one other thing
that they do in their business model is
that they're really focused on hiring
formerly incarcerated individuals for
their business model they're focused on
also meeting that other social objective
of help
with re-entry for people who have a hard
time finding jobs after they've been
incarcerated so really you can see with
a company like this they have multiple
different social objectives
environmental objectives all in one and
this is sort of an interesting case that
we think is kind of a micro example of a
lot of what we're seeing in the impact
investing space and these are the types
of companies within it so anyway within
the form put in the company name so made
meals as I just said and then there's
all sorts of different fields with
dropdowns so I'll skip over the first
couple just as an example I'll show the
industry so right here there's an
industry and we have a drop-down it's
long but it actually links to all of the
different industry options within the
impact space data source so if made
meals for instance says okay we're in
the agriculture business that's that's
great they're in the agriculture
business that being said we don't know
how much that's relevant to the
particular user startup and that needs
to be up to their discretion to tell us
so if agriculture is sort of their main
industry then they have this option to
weight it at a particularly high level
and so they can actually right now enter
any type of weight that they want we're
ultimately going to try to streamline it
to be just a set of options potentially
0 through 3 where they can pick the
strongest weight and then what happens
is that field is then run against the
entity store of all of the different
companies within that entity store that
have an industry of agriculture so every
time a company with agriculture as one
of their industries is found within our
entity store the weight that the user
assigns is then added on to what becomes
a cumulative total for the particular
user company using our form and so the
idea here is that ok so I weight
industry 1 agriculture and I weight it
with a 3 that's my top weight for me as
the user and then I go down and then get
here to social objectives I'm just
skipping over some of the other ones
just to show you the example I get to
social objectives health improvement
based on our conversations with the made
meals founder that's their number one
social objective okay so if I'm him
I'll weight this then as a three as the
top weight food security that's another
one very important as well I'll weight
that as a three and then like I said
before you're working you know on
re-entry programs or formally
incarcerated individuals so this other
social objective of equality and
empowerment of minorities or previously
excluded populations that's something as
well that I'd like to include it just
doesn't happen to be the main social
objective so maybe I'll weight that as a
two rather than a three so again this is
all run through that string matching
function against all the companies
within the entity stores against all of
their corresponding social objectives
and then each time one of these
different entries is found the
corresponding weight is then added to
the total so you go through again you
have environmental objectives
sustainable land use that's something
for for made meals that would be
relevant to them natural resource
conservation you could say that that's
relevant and so they would go through
and then finally they would get to this
keyword category and based on our
initial testing of this app form this
tends to be the most important category
because this is what really allows the
startup to get into that level of
granularity where they're able to really
distinguish themselves and what it is
that they do specifically and
differently from the field and so made
meals obviously we look at their company
overview when we do this but this will
be up to the company user to determine
based on their own discretion meals is
something that's important in the
business model ingredients you know
words like incarcerated organic those
are all things that we'll put in here
and then weight at the highest weight
and and then you get to this last field
where you see the number of companies to
return the default is 22 let's say we
just go with the default and we press
okay and then we get to this output of
the top weighted peers and so just from
eyeball and you can see by this output
my Yoko's kitchen mindful meats that
sounds very similar to made meals you
know and just look at some of these in
farm bio core you you already start to
see that
they are probably very good matches to
made meals and then they're weighted
totals are all next to them and the way
that the algorithm is working its
ranking them in order of their weighted
totals so within the app concept we're
not going to show you everything
interactively right now as Maureen
mentioned it's formative and there's a
lot of different things that you can do
with the entity store structure that
we're using but users can then click on
these different companies and see
interactively you know which ones of
them have received impact investment in
the past and who they've received the
investment from so then they can start
to look into the different investors
that have given to these similar
companies to them and and you know this
is something that we're going to
continue to build out and figure out how
to automate in a way that's that's
really actionable for them but that's
within this current initial version and
then just getting down here you see this
little screenshot you're also able to
export all of the output data on each of
the top weighted companies that are
returned into a CSV file and so here's
just a screenshot of that and you see
all of these same companies above but
now pulling their entity store data
within our entity store and then putting
it into that CSV file here so that's
that part and I'll just move on very
quickly here so applying machine
learning that's something that we're
altima trying to do with this app
concept obviously algorithmically we
have it working it's effective we've
tested it with startup users and we're
happy with the results and so are they
that being said we want to actually get
to the point where we can predict or
recommend the highest probability
funders for each user startup using
again this finely tuned classifier
function that that wolfram allows us to
use trained on data that is highly
integrated from across these different
sources that we've mentioned and so the
steps just to run through them quickly
because I know we're running short on
time here but extracting structuring and
storing a large enough data set from
multiple sources this is something we've
already done and so we're pretty
confident in our ability to continue to
be able to do this next is building a
classifier function or set of functions
to begin to
actually integrate company data from the
different data sources that were using
all into the singular entity store that
will sort of serve as the foundation of
this app I'll get into that a little bit
later third is to really build that
classifier function through a set of
trained impact investor data from our
entities stores where like I mentioned
before investors will actually be
trained on the company overviews along
with some of the other fields of their
investment companies or of the companies
that they're actually investing in we're
gonna then test obviously the classifier
functions that we're building on new
sets of tests data and then ultimately
the final step will really be to be able
to provide startups with their strongest
funding opportunities including the
Associated probabilities of you know of
funders being strong matches or the best
possible options for what they're doing
the results so far just getting into
this section here so as I mentioned
before one of the things we're trying to
do is use the machine learning
capabilities within Wolfram to integrate
data from different sources we've
actually already begun training and
testing a classifier function that helps
integrate and assign companies from
external data sources and the early
results are actually very positive and
we're here we have just a little
screenshot here of us running the
classifier function on an overview of a
company from a different data source
this this case is B Corp and from the
overview it's able to say it's called
Buddy media it's a social enterprise
software company empowering those to
build and maintain relationships with
their consumers and so what we're seeing
here is that it's actually assigning
this as access to information with a
very high probability obviously it needs
to be tweaked and tested stronger but
but it is an exciting development as we
we also want to begin to train the data
on the impact investors and the
overviews that we mentioned a little bit
earlier so this brings us then to our
final slide here which is our our
challenge is an opportunity section and
so as you saw from our app form user
interfacing obviously a going to be a
challenge for us ahead but also a strong
opportunity for us so we want to really
continue
tweaking the interface specifically so
that the numerical weighting system
becomes more executed more heavily in
the backend rather than potentially by
the user themselves so that's just
easier to use in all areas we want to
experiment with you know different types
of user facing or internal algorithmic
weightings to fine-tune machine learning
training sets we're going to like I said
before the ultimate goal is to build out
an automated report template so that
you're not just getting sort of a data
set or an Excel spreadsheet with all the
peers but you're actually getting
actionable results in a report as your
output after using the app and then
again developing an automated system to
actually update our entity stores on a
regular basis so that we're staying
up-to-date with all of the impact
investment data that's that's currently
out there when it comes to machine
learning we just went through a lot of
that we're already sort of meaning this
first bullet point here using wolfram
machine learning to integrate additional
data sources one other thing that we're
going to do and and my colleague Ben as
well as Maureen we'll talk about this
more in our presentation tomorrow but
we're going to want to actually create
some machine learning classifier
functions tailored specifically to the
SDGs the UN sustainable development
goals as we found in our work that those
also help investors or sorry rather
companies attract impact investors and
then again these are sort of the last
two major major opportunities that are
probably longer down the road here but
ultimately what we want to be able to do
is identify the core areas of strength
in successful companies you know whether
it's their website content their social
media content business structure or
social objectives to provide actionable
recommendations to improve impact
investment positioning for client
companies doing automated analysis of
all those same fields so again website
content and social media and what have
you and then lastly here just creating a
system to automatically track the impact
investment progress of startup users
over time will be something that we're
looking to do as well so that we can
actually begin to measure the efficacy
of our app form here
and I just want to repeat why we love
Wolfram the data is formative we're
finding the different different
databases have different kinds of
descriptions of things that will be
relatable once we figure out how to
relate them we were at the neural
network repository session this morning
and we saw probably three different
neural networks and ways to train that
are going to help us get these
classifiers better as the field emerges
we expect that well from Wilfred when we
are moving in parallel in certain ways
so we're looking forward to it was
exciting actually be here Steve ago from
last night say that something is going
to be incorporated that we sort of have
invented in our sort of homebrew version
and we also think that a lot of the data
that we're gathering will have some
robustness for the overall wolf of
repositories over time so we're
gathering sort of a new dimension of
data for companies and financials in
this and for SD G's and World Bank data
and things in that so we're very excited
to be playing this game we expect this
hasn't got to be finished any time soon
we don't see it is needing to be
finished because wolf was pretty good at
being iterative as well